nous avons commencé nous nous avons
terminé cette conférence est qui a duré
cinq heures
la conférence que nous avons préparée
depuis quatre mois
nous avons procédé à cinq séances de
consultation et à l'issue nous avons
concerté un document assez détaillée qui
contient des recommandations et des
propositions qui visent au règlement de
la crise les biens il ya quelques
chapitres unsa pitre sécuritaire pour
rétablir le cessez le feu il y a le
volet qui est consacrée au processus
politique mais aussi aux problèmes
économiques vu que toutes les parties
libyennes
je te les groupes religieux ethniques
politiques doivent avoir accès aux
ressources naturelles et il y à un
chapitre qui concerne le respect des
droits de l'homme
le problème humanitaire et les mesures
qui se tient demain c'est fort de la
part de la communauté internationale
sous l'égide des nations unies la russie
à participer à la préparation de cette
conférence et dès le début nous avons
pris part à cinq séances de préparation
et sur proposition de russie les
organisateurs answer abandonner leur
volonté de ne pas éviter les parties
libyennes
ils ont invité monsieur al sa rage et le
chef de l'armée nationale libyenne de
maréchal afta rec et sur initiatives
russes nous avons élargi les
participants à
je veux dire les voisins de la libye
plus qu'il faut prendre en compte les
intérêts de ces pays puisque pour que
toutes les ententes soient stables et le
troisième aspect qui était la
proposition de la russie
c'est de réitérer les clauses de
principe onusienne qui concerne le
constat de du refuse de la voie
militaire est la voie armée et le
règlement du conflit par les libyens eux
mêmes sans ingérence de l'extérieur et
nous avons réussi a rédigé un document
final qui contient toutes les
propositions et toutes les
recommandations qui doivent être
avalisées par les parties en libye et
nous avons réitéré le rôle du conseil de
sécurité
le conseil de sécurité va étudier ce
document et va formuler sa position le
président poutine a formulé notre
position et il a souligné que lors de
cet examen au conseil de sécurité
nous allons prendre en compte l'avis des
libyens et avant que le conseil de
sécurité soit en mesure de l'étudier
nous devons avoir cette avis des libyens
les situations des filles est difficile
elle est partie libyenne ont fait un pas
en avant par rapport à la conférence à
moscou
ils se sont entendus de délégués cinq
représentants au comité militaire à
l'initiative onusienne et ce comité va
examiner toutes les questions sur la
trêve
la trêve est effective depuis tous
janvier sur l'initiative russe et turque
ihh on respecte
en général cette trêve quoique il il ya
certaines
violation de cette trêve et les pays qui
sont influents en libye se sont engagés
de ne pas entreprendre des démarches qui
vont inciter les parties libyennes à
reprendre des ses actions armées et vont
contribuer à la consolidation de la paix
et de la trêve est donc ce qu'ont ces
militaires et qui va être fort de cinq
représentants de la part d'al sa rage et
de haftar va mettre au point les mesures
de confiance pour stabiliser cette trêve
nous considérons que cette conférence
était bien utile
cette aux libyens de prendre de décision
pour le moment et nous n'avons pas
réussi à établir un dialogue continu
entre ces deux parties mais de toute
façon les propositions et les
recommandations que contient le document
final de conférence de berlin complète
les idées qui sont proposés par la
communauté internationale pour que ses
partis soient en mesure d'être à table
des négociations
merci beaucoup